connexio n'est pas la première fois que
la droite parlementaire montre ses
muscles sur le sujet du communautarisme
et de l'islamisme changer les textes
pour faire appliquer la laïcité c'est
bien mais respecter ses principes et ne
pas faire la courte échelle aux frères
musulmans quand on dirige des
collectivités c'est mieux la formulation
de votre loi est trop vague trop naître
nous avons un ennemi l'islamisme il ne
se prend il ne s'entraîne pas qu'à la
république
ils attaquent des français ils tuent des
français en france
l'islamisme ne se répande partout mes
chers collègues que c'est comme une
gangrène ils s'infiltrent y serais pas
ici on ne coupe pas le membre malade on
en meurt et quand je dis partout je
parle aussi de notre vénérable assemblée
oui au coeur du sénat du coeur battant
de notre démocratie l'islamisme
s'installe une nous rend visite en toute
tranquillité je pense surtout et avant
tout à ceux qui siègent à droite qui
parle fort mais dans les arrière-salles
s'accommode avec les islamistes
depuis des années ils le font à l'abri
des regards il est temps que les
français sachent
je pense évidemment une sénatrice des
alpes-maritimes accessoirement membre de
la communauté de la commission d'
enquête sur l'islamisme est bien là même
sénatrice accueillis au sénat en
décembre 2019 des membres niçois de
l'association de jeunesse cellier un
lieu hier la branche française des
frères musulmans considérés je le
rappelle comme une organisation
terroriste dans de nombreux pays y
compris musulmans je pense aussi à une
autre de nos collègues nouvellement élus
à leurs mères des 11e et 12e
arrondissements de marseille qui a
laissé les mosquées salafistes
s'installer dans un local municipal de
son secteur
toujours en mars et à une adjointe au
maire vice présidente de la région paca
a représenté le président de la région
lors de la rencontre annuelle des
musulmans du sud organisé par l'ue
relief bien sûr en octobre 2019 chers
sénateurs de droite
il est temps de laver le linge sale qui
empestent votre famille politique
la mairie de nice a même été condamné en
2013 pour avoir violé la loi de 1905
car elle avait loué un local municipal à
un loyer dérisoire au bénéfice d'une
mosquée liée à al youssef
le maire et sa majorité ont aussi
subventionner l'association islamiste
invité par la sénatrice des
alpes-maritimes l'islamisme pourri la
politique française ce sont les écuries
d'augias qu'il faut nettoyer
et ça commence par votre famille
politique la droite du vert mais surtout
la droite de la lâcheté et des trahisons
fait le ménage chez vous avant de venir
faire la leçon aux autres soyez vraiment
courageux et sanctionner les membres de
votre famille politique qui collaborent
avec les islamistes
rompez tous les liens qui unissent vos
élus aux islamistes avant que d'autres
français ne tombent sous les coups de
ses fanatiques l'islamisme on ne s'en
accommode pas on ne s'en approchent même
pas on le combat est on là bas